But I want to pick up where
we left off on Monday.
We were talking about the
three Bravais lattices.
There a couple more things
that I want to say about them.
What we captured,
the key essence,
apart from they're being
these cubic crystals
and the different
elements that form them,
is this idea that you can
go from the unit cell,
once you know the unit cell,
you can get the atomic radius.
So that's kind of cool.
Because you know
information about things
like, for example, packing.
So then we had the packing
fraction, the atomic packing
fraction.
Calculated that.
The maximum, the max
packing fraction.
Packing fraction.
We calculated things like
the closed pack direction.
Well, you can also go to
things like the density.
Once you know how to
go back and forth.
And so for example, if I want
the density of a material,
that's grams per
centimeter cubed, right?
That's the density.
But you could write the
density in terms of the things
we talked about on Monday.
So again, you know,
I want you to be
able to go back and forth.
Once you know the unit cell,
and you can know something
about the radius of the atom,
then you can get the density.
For example, here,
the density could
be defined as the
number of atoms
in the cell, times the grams
per mole of that element,
divided by the volume of
the cell, of the unit cell,
times Avogadro.
Now, you can go
through the units
and you can work out that this
is grams per centimeter cubed.
So just as an example,
if I had, let's see,
the example I have is copper.
So example, copper.
So you know, everything comes
from the periodic table.
Everything.
Life, class, everything comes
from the periodic table.
So I go--
I say, I want to know--
I go to the periodic table.
And instead of looking
up the density,
I look up other things.
So I look up, for
example, that it's FCC.
And then I look up that
it's 63.55 grams per mole.
And I also look up
the atomic radius.
So I look up these
things, the atomic radius.
And that's equal
to 1.3 angstroms.
So I look all this stuff up.
And the point is, I can
now go back and forth.
I can use the
information, because I
know if it's a crystal and
I know the crystal type,
FCC, then I can use
this information
to get other aspects, right?
So other properties.
So for example, I know that the
radius of the atom for an FCC,
if it's close packed, if it's--
you know, FCC one element,
remember it grows
out until they touch.
And that got us how we get
the radius of the atom.
And it's a root 2 over 4.
But I also know that there's
four atoms per unit cell
because it's FCC.
I also know that the
volume of the cell
is simply the lattice
constant cubed
because it's a cubic cell.
All the ones here are cubic.
So the volume of
these cells are cubic.
From this information, I
can compute the density.
So again, it's going
back and forth.
The radius of the atoms packed
in, the lattice constants,
the number of atoms
in the cell, these
are the things we
talked about on Monday.
And as you go back and forth,
you can do things like this.
All right, good.
Now we talked about the--
we talked about the Bravais
lattice there, right?
And those are three
Bravais lattices that I
want you to know.
Bravais lattices.
But the thing is that
there's something else
you need to know in order to
know what crystal you have.
And so this is the
FCC Bravais lattice.
There it is.
It's over there on the right.
It's the face-centered cubic.
OK, gesundheit.
And I'm going to
pass this around.
All right, oh yeah,
I'm starting over here
because I keep on starting
over there and it's not fair.
That's not right.
Yeah, all right.
Got a couple--
OK, so that's FCC, right?
So we're going to
write down FCC.
But the thing is is that
see, this is our stamp.
Remember, it's a stamp of
points that are equivalent.
That's what the
lattice vectors are.
They are not the things
that you put at that point.
That is something else.
Now, on Monday, we put
the things there were
atoms, spherical particles.
And they're all the same.
That was their introduction
to crystallography.
But the basis can be more
than just a single atom.
It can be more.
So how do we think
about the basis?
So here's a lattice.
This is a lattice of points.
The way you want to
think about a lattice
is a stamp without
putting things there yet.
The basis is what you put there.
Let's write that down
because it's so important.
So the lattice is
all we're going--
oh, I'm going all
caps, how to repeat.
And the basis is what to repeat.
So if this is my
lattice and I decide
that I want to get a million
downloads on YouTube,
I'm going to put a cap there.
And this is my crystal.
It's a crystal of cats.
That's OK.
I have done nothing wrong.
Because I have simply,
according to the rules
of crystallography, I've
had a lattice and a basis.
And I've just defined
my basis as a cat.
And that's the crystal you get.
But see, the basis could
also have been, for example,
two atoms colored
differently to show
that they are different atoms.
And then this would
be my crystal.
So the actual
crystal that you get
may be different than
the lattice structure.
All right, so let's take a look.
So for example,
over here, you know,
if my basis is a single
atom, nickel, copper, gold,
platinum, well, I showed you
these from the periodic table
on Monday, right?
We highlighted them when
we talked about FCC.
Then the crystal
that you get is FCC.
These are the ones
we did on Monday.
Those are FCC crystals.
But at the same
time, if my basis--
check this out.
Oh, this is salt. When you
guys pour salt on your food,
do not see it any
more except as this.
This is salt. This
is salt. It is--
let's see-- simple cubic.
Is it, though?
Because a lattice,
a simple cubic--
remember the definition.
A simple cubic lattice would
mean a stamp of a simple cube
where every corner is exactly
the same, exactly the same.
That's what a lattice is.
So this cannot be a simple cube.
This is not simple cubic
because they're different.
They're different.
At the corners, I've
got two blues and then
two red and then
two other blues.
So they're not the same.
It cannot be a simple
cubic structure.
This is an FCC lattice.
This is an FCC.
Yeah, I'm starting
over here again.
I'm trying to even it out.
That's an FCC lattice, but with
a basis of sodium and chlorine.
So it's an FCC.
You can call it an FCC lattice.
But the basis is a
sodium chloride pair.
And this has a name.
It's called the
rock salt structure.
It's an FCC lattice with this
two atom basis where, look,
you can see the
FCC lattice here.
Look at those blue
points, right?
Blue outlines an FCC lattice.
But now the basis is one
atom here and one there.
So now I take that, this
pair, and I put that
at all the lattice points.
You see that?
You put that in all the
lattice points of FCC
and you've got salt.
And that is how you must
see table salt from now on.
Well, we talked about diamond.
This is diamond.
Diamond is the same
Bravais lattice.
It doesn't look
like it at first.
But see here, I have
a different pair.
Here I have a
carbon-carbon pair.
Or it could be, or
silicon-silicon.
There are actually a
number of pairs of that
would form this diamond.
In fact, we specify because
there are different types.
This is called cubic
diamond crystal.
This is the cubic
What is the lattice?
It's FCC.
Now, let's take a look at that.
Look, there is my FCC.
Here, here, here, here.
But inside of the FCC, I've
got this pair of carbon atoms.
Now they're the
same type of atom.
And instead of one being
kind of in the middle
of this edge, as it was with
sodium and chlorine, now
the other atom is kind
of off in a diagonal.
But it's still just
a pair of atoms.
It's a pair of carbon atoms.
But if you look
carefully at diamond,
and this doesn't go
on in this picture,
but it does in real life,
this is an FCC lattice
of these pairs,
repeating everywhere.
That's what diamond is.
It's an FCC lattice.
So the symmetry is FCC.
But the basis is a
carbon-carbon dimer, right?
And that gives
you cubic diamond.
OK, so there's the
Bravais lattice
and there's the resulting
crystal structure.
Now, speaking of diamond.
And this is a graph that
I showed you a while ago
when we were talking about the
differences between diamond
and graphite.
One of the things that you
can see that's so important,
this is the same element, two
different crystal structures.
One of the things that you
can see that is so important
is how direction is going
to be an important property.
You need to know how
to identify direction
because you know, in this case,
it looks like maybe if I point
in different directions,
the thing would
look kind of the same, or maybe
have similar properties along--
but look at this.
This looks seriously
directionally dependent.
It looks like if I
did something like
tried to carry charge or
thermal energy this way,
then it would be
very, very different
than if I carried it this way.
Well, we have a word for that.
And it's called anisotropy.
And so this is another
important word, anisotropy.
If it's anisotropic,
then the property,
well, it could be like
electrical or thermal
conductivity, for example.
Thermal conductivity could
be like how it breaks,
the fracture.
And so on.
But whatever-- but
the property is--
depends.
I'll just say it's
directionally dependent.
Directionally dependent.
So the reason I'm telling you
this is that I now need a way--
we've come up with sort of
ways to talk about crystals.
But I now need a way to specify
where I am in a crystal.
And maybe how the crystal cuts.
I need a way to talk
about directionality
in these crystals.
And that's what I want you to--
that's the topic for today.
So the first question--
well, to jump to
the punch line is
there are these things
called Miller indices.
And that's what we're
going to learn today.
Miller indices and they describe
direction and cuts, planes.
OK, and the first question
you can ask is, where are you?
Where are you?
Now it turns out that there
are these people called
crystallographers.
And they came up with
crystallography over the years.
And they have very strong
ideas about notation.
So we'll be talking about
crystallographer notation.
And we'll be very careful
not to do anything
that would upset a
crystallographer because that
is not something
you want to see.
But the first question that you
could ask is, where are you?
So I'm going to draw the planes
and we're going to-- the axes--
and we're always going
to use the same notation,
the same axis directions,
just for simplicity.
In this class,
we're going to say
that as we're talking
about crystal structures,
that's y, that's
z, and that's x.
x is coming out of the board.
y is it going that way
and z is going that way.
Now, if I want to know where
I am, then what I can do
is draw the cube.
Oh boy, here we go.
OK, there it is.
And I can just start
looking at points.
But instead of having all
sorts of different numbers,
crystallographers like to
work with simple numbers.
So what we do is we
define the position
as the fraction
of the cell edge.
OK, so what that means is if,
you know, OK first of all,
the origin is 0, 0, 0.
So that's 0, 0, 0.
But it also means that
if I had this point here,
that's going to be 1, 0, 0.
Doesn't matter what a is.
Remember, a is the
lattice constant.
It's the edge of the cube,
which has a real value
in different crystals.
There's copper.
There's a in copper,
which we could compute.
But no, when we specify
positions in crystal,
we do it as a fraction
of that length.
OK, so that-- so this
point, for example,
would be 1, 1, 1 out there.
All right.
And let's do one more.
This point here.
All right, well that's going
to be-- gesundheit-- that's
going to be over a half now.
So it's a half and then 1, 0.
It went over a
half, over 1, up 0.
So it's a 1/2.
OK, good.
This is just where we are.
We're just getting warmed up.
But really what we need to
know is where we're going.
And that goes from
a point to a vector.
OK, now again, there are some
fairly straightforward rules
that we follow not that we
don't know what vectors are.
We know what vectors are.
The point is, do we know how
to specify a vector in a way
that a crystallographer
would be happy with?
That's what we have to learn.
Because again, we don't
want to make them upset.
So there is a set of very simple
rules that you can follow.
And I've got this
for the direction
and I've got this
for the planes.
So here are the rules
for the direction.
Here's a vector in a crystal.
Origin o and here are
different vectors.
And what we do is
we, OK, we position
it to start at the origin.
And then we read
off the projections
in terms of the unit
cell dimensions.
a is x.
b is y and c is z.
Now, we know that those of the
same length in a cubic crystal.
Adjust to the smallest
integer values,
that's really important.
And enclose in square brackets.
No commas.
So let's do a few.
So oa, here are
the xyz read out.
Well you know, this is 1.
This is 0.
So this would give us this as
the notation for the oa vector.
You see that there, right?
Notice I've already
done step two.
So the second bullet
there, read off
projections in terms of
unit cell dimensions,
a, b, and c, because it went
all the way to the edge.
So it's a 1.
It didn't go halfway.
It's not 1/2.
OK, good.
So ob, OK, well that's going to
be 1 along x, 1 along y, and 0.
So that direction would
be written as the 110.
And oc would be 111.
This is feeling kind of boring.
Oh, gesundheit.
But it gets exciting
in just a sec.
Because all we're doing here is
we're going OK, 100, 110, 111.
OK, good.
But now we go to od.
Now, od is one of these cases
where we have to be careful.
So od, you see that?
It's going from here to there.
So along the x
direction, it's still
going a full one of the edge.
Along the y direction, it's 0.
But along the z
direction, it's 1/2.
And so because crystallographers
don't like fractions
when they talk about directions,
we have to scale that up.
And so we just get rid of it.
We multiply everything by 2.
We put it in brackets.
And everyone is happy.
201.
That is the 201 direction.
In this crystal.
They don't like fractions.
Now, they don't like
negative signs either.
They don't like negative signs.
But so if I were doing--
if I were doing
oe, OK, that's just
going in the other direction.
So oe would be--
let's see-- minus--
OK, well if I just
jumped to what
we think it might be
given what we just saw,
it would look like that.
But crystallographers don't
like having negative, you
know, these minuses
inside of their brackets.
So we write a bar.
So we write it like this.
0, 1 bar, 0.
And that is the
notation for going
in the negative direction.
OK, 01bar0.
That would be oe.
Did I get that right? oe, Yeah.
And you can see that of, if
you have the same kind of fun,
you would see that of is the
112 direction, that that's
how you would write
the of vector right
because you got 1/2, 1/2 and
1, but they don't like the 1/2.
So you multiply through
by 2, you get the 112.
These are vectors in crystals.
Now, there are equivalences
here because this
is a cubic lattice.
So if I look at this and say,
well, OK, if I went this way
and I went that way, where I
wind up are equivalent points.
Right, where I wind
up is, you know,
you're winding up at the same
place in a way in the crystal
because the definition of
that stamp in a cubic lattice
is that those are
all equivalent.
Doesn't matter
what's on your basis.
Because it's defined
by the Bravais lattice.
That's to stamp.
So we have a way of
writing that, too.
So the 101.
That's the 101 direction
and the 110 direction, cool.
If I make it a little
simpler, you know,
I can say that the 100 and
the 010 and the 001, oh,
let's do them all.
And the 1bar00 and the 01bar0,
and the 001bar all get me
to equivalent places.
And we can call this a
family, just because we don't
want to keep writing them.
If they're all
equivalent, we can say
this is a family of directions.
And you've got to
be careful here
because you can't use a bracket
anymore because it would just
be one of the directions.
Instead, we use-- sorry, you
can't use the square brackets.
Instead, we use
this kind of bracket
and we say it's the 100 family.
So if you see a direction
written with brackets
like that, then it means
all of these directions,
this family of directions.
But if you see it written
with a bracket like this,
it means that one vector.
Crystallographers, you've
got to keep them happy.
You've got to keep them happy.
All right, now,
that is directions.
That is direction.
But what about cuts?
What about planes?
So we've got our vectors,
now we need our cuts.
We've got to be able to
specify these things.
And you know, as we'll
see, as we'll see,
the properties of materials,
of crystals, especially
the more anisotropic they
are, depend very heavily
on what's in what direction.
So for example, if I have
a plane in a crystal that
doesn't have a high
density of atoms,
and then I got
another plane that's
got a lot of density
of atoms in that plane,
well you might expect those
to have different responses
to, for example,
mechanical stress, strain.
You push it.
You pull it.
You break it.
You hammer it.
Maybe one of those
planes, if it doesn't
have as many bonds in
it, might break first.
This is just one example.
So we've got to know how
to talk about these things.
We've got to know how to
talk about these things.
So now with planes,
I have another recipe
to make crystallographers happy.
Now first read off--
oh, well let's
put an example up.
So I've got an example.
I'll do a few.
And then as always, you guys
need to do more to practice.
So I'll do a few.
So I'm going to
draw a plane and I'm
going to make it
a nice simple one.
These are my axes, x, y, z.
And I'm going to draw
my cubic crystal--
my cubic unit cell, sorry.
OK, here we go.
Almost a cube.
OK, now I want to
take a plane here.
I'm going to take this top one.
So I'm going to take this and
I'm going to go through those--
I want to know,
how do I describe
that plane that cuts that way?
OK, one, these correspond to
those, crystal plane algorithm.
I hear a few of you like
algorithms and computing
in course six.
We got one whistle.
So here's the thing, if I have
a plane like this and I ask you,
where does it intercept?
Where does it
intercept the axis?
Right, well, it's never going
to intercept the x and y axes,
never.
It's never going to intercept
them, no matter what I do.
But you say, but what if I
put it in the xy plane, then
it's always
intercept-- no, that's
not what we mean by intercept.
What I mean by intercept is,
it has to reach them eventually
no matter where it is, no
matter where I position it.
But this never does.
This never does.
And so the intercepts, you
know, for the ABC intercepts,
so we can write those here.
OK, I'll write the same way, x,
y, z intercepts, it's infinite.
And it's infinite.
All right, and then
for the z, OK here,
I'm intercepting
at this part of z.
So I'm intercepting at 1.
But the thing is, oh
man, crystallographers
don't like infinity either.
They don't.
And so what they do is
they just take 1 over.
That's a nice way
to fix infinity.
And so step two, this would
become 00 and 1 over 1 is 1.
Right, 1 over infinity is 0.
Now we reduce to integer
values and there's
no work to do there.
And then we are very
careful about this.
We use parentheses.
No more brackets, parentheses.
Do not get this wrong
because you might be talking
about a vector by accident.
You don't want to talk
So this is the 001
plane, no commas.
Remember the dislike of commas.
It's the 001 plane
in this crystal.
That is a cut.
OK, good.
And that's called
a Miller plane.
Well, if I do another
example, do one more,
so that is this one.
I have it.
I've got a bunch
of examples here.
And they can draw it, you
know, better with the shading
and stuff there.
But you see, that's
what we just did.
We did the 001 plane,
that one there.
All right, there it
is, nice and big.
The 001 plane.
What about that one?
That's the 110.
The 110, if you do
the 110, 110, I'm
not going to try
to draw it again,
what you get is step
one, you get 11infinity.
Step two, you get 110.
Step three, you get 110.
and step four, you get 110.
Those are the steps to
identifying and labeling
a crystal plane.
Let's make it a little
more complicated.
We still haven't
really done something
where we take advantage
of the rule of step three.
So let's make it harder.
Let's bump it up.
So there's a slice.
Remember, I can slice a
crystal in any way I want.
And I got to be able
to write it down.
I got to be able to
represent it on paper.
That's what this is about.
That's what the Miller
indices and the Miller planes
let us do.
So this one I'm
going to try to draw.
So here, I've got my axes.
And that's y.
And that's x.
And that's z.
Here we go.
It's almost a cube.
Now, I've gone up
here to 3/4 high.
So I've gone up about 3/4 there.
I've gone here to 1/2.
That's 1/2 of the cell length.
This is 3/4 of the cell length.
And then over, I've
gone all the way to 1.
So now if I go through my steps
on this one, I've got a 1/2,
and I've got 1,
and I've got 3/4.
OK, I'm going to
take the reciprocals.
OK, that becomes 21 4/3.
Oh, not happy yet.
Not happy yet.
We don't like fractions.
We got to get rid of fractions.
So in step three, we simply
multiply through by 3.
And we get 634.
And then we can write
down that point.
That is 634 plane.
And so on and so on.
Now, let's go back to--
let me erase this.
There's a couple of
things about the planes
that once we know
what the plane is,
we know some other
things about it.
So let's talk about that now.
All right, if I--
first of all, a Miller
plane is not just one plane.
A Miller plane is
not just one plane.
A Miller plane is an
infinite set of planes.
OK so when I say a Miller plane,
well, very often what you do
is what we've been
doing, which is
you define the plane
that's kind of closest,
somehow, to the origin.
In the unit cell,
the one that cuts it.
You define it that way.
But actually, what
Miller planes are
are infinite sets of planes.
And so I'm going to put--
Now, I'm not a crystallographer
so I can write infinity.
I'm OK with that.
It's an infinite set of planes.
OK.
They are equally spaced
and here's the key,
one should always be
going through the origin.
If you want to look at
it as a set of planes,
you've got to put
one at the origin.
That will help you think
through what I mean.
OK, so if one goes
through the origin,
then what you see right
away is how they repeat.
Because you know, it's not
just that I go-- in that case,
let's take that one, the 001.
Now you say, where's the next 1
in this infinite set of planes?
OK, well, put that one at the
origin and make another one.
Then put that one at the origin
again and make another one.
That's how to think about
this infinite set of planes.
OK?
So if I had one
that went half way,
a 200 plane or an 002 plane,
as it would be if it's properly
noted with Miller indices,
well then you say, well, OK,
I've got one half way.
You know, isn't that it?
No.
The set of infinite
planes also would have one
at the origin, one half
way, one at the top.
Because each time you put it
back and you do your next one.
That's how to think about this
infinite set of Miller planes.
So you get this infinite
set of planes that have--
I'm going to go to this picture.
There it is, a 100,
that just go on forever.
Those are the Miller planes.
And what they have is
a spacing between them.
And this is really important.
So this is the next
thing I want to tell you.
All right, so I've got-- so a
Miller plane isn't just one,
it's infinite.
It's an infinite number of them.
And what that means is
that when I give you--
when I give you this, right,
or that, or any Miller plane,
I know what the spacing
is between them.
That is enough information.
Because the distance
between planes is--
actually, here it's
very easy to see.
The distance between
these planes is a.
But the difference between
the 200 planes is a over 2.
And in fact, for a
cubic cell, there's
a formula that you can
use for any two planes.
The distance between,
well, let's see.
I'll write the notation first.
The distance and the
plane there is equal to a.
And the distance of a
200 plane between planes
is equal to a over 2.
But there's a general
formula of any HKL.
HKL, the Miller indices.
Those are just variables.
But if those are the
variables of the Miller plane,
then the distance
between two of them
is the length of the
edge of the unit cell, a,
divided by the square root of
the squares added together,
a squared plus k
squared plus l squared.
So you see, OK, if
it's 100, that a.
That works.
If it's 200, that works.
And it's general.
So now, just by knowing,
but because I figured out
how to write a plane
in HKL notation,
I also know the distance
between these infinite planes.
That becomes very,
very important
once we shine x-rays
on crystals next week.
That becomes very important.
OK?
OK, so what else can we
know from the Miller planes?
OK, so that's the
distance between them.
Now the other thing that
actually becomes fairly
self-evident when you play
around with this a little bit,
and that was on the
slide before, is that--
let's see.
The plane and direction
with the same Miller indices
are orthogonal.
And you can see this from
this very simple picture.
There's the 001 plane.
But that's also the 001 vector,
just as we defined it today.
So the 001 plane and the
001 vector are orthogonal.
So this is an example, the 001
plane is orthogonal to, oh,
now gotta get this
right, the 001 vector.
Oh, no commas.
Brackets, parentheses, no
negatives, no fractions,
no infinities.
I followed the rules.
And because of
that, these indices
have meaning as I'm showing
you, because of that.
Now, you can play
around with this
but this can also be
fairly straightforwardly
derived, things like this.
But you don't need to
know that derivation
so I'm just telling it to you.
OK, so these are the
kinds of things that you
can do with Miller indices.
As I said in the beginning.
One of the things
that you would want
to know what planes
you're talking about
is because you want to know what
the packing in that plane is.
Just like we talked
about packing, right--
well, we talked about it before
on Monday, the atomic packing
fraction, there it is, the max
packing fraction in a volume.
We also want to know, especially
if a crystal is anisotropy,
we want to know about
packings in planes.
And so, you know, if you
take a very simple example
like a simple cubic, there's
a simple cubic lattice.
And now we're all good
with our notation.
There's a simple cubic crystal.
The basis is one atom.
I don't have anything
else in here.
Those are the atoms.
It must be polonium.
And there's the 100
plane, the 110 plane,
and the 111 plane, 111
plane, 110 plane, 100 plane.
Now as you can see, the density
of atoms in these planes
is different.
The density of atoms in
these planes is different.
And that has a real serious
impact on the properties.
So if we look at this--
so I'll do a couple
of quick examples.
If we look at this
example of simple cubic,
that's a very easy case.
And so for a simple
cubic with a lattice--
this a is called the
lattice constant.
I've mentioned it a few times.
Lattice constant a.
Then you know, if we
look at the 100 plane,
then the area is a squared.
The area of that
plane is a squared.
But the question is, how many
atoms are in that a squared.
Well, you do the same
thing that we did before.
So I'm looking at a plane here.
And I'm trying to figure out how
many atoms are in this-- well,
you know this is being shared
in this whole big plane that
goes on and on.
It's being shared by
four other squares.
And so there's a fourth
of each atom in there.
So there's one atom,
effectively, in that plane.
Again, this is in one
of the simplest cases.
But the number atoms equal to 1.
And so the density
of atoms per area
is equal to 1 over a squared.
That's a pretty easy case.
If I did the 110 direction,
it's a little bit different
because the area
is now different.
So the area in this case
is root 2 a squared.
You see that?
The area in that
plane is different.
So the density of atoms
in the plane is different.
So the density in the
plane affects properties.
And I want to give you just
a quick example of that
and why this matters.
Because in fact, this
is one of the things,
all the way back to Hook
and his cannonballs,
and even way before that,
people noticed this stuff.
I broke something,
but it always seems
to slice in a certain way.
Why is that?
Why would something always break
in the same way every time?
With the same kind of--
what does way mean here?
It means like the
angles that form.
So why are those angles
always kind of the same?
Well, it has to do
with the strength,
the relative strength,
of the planes
inside of these crystals.
And in fact, here's
a beautiful piece
of work on stretching a wire.
All right, so here you're taking
a wire that is crystalline
and you're pulling it.
And you can see how it breaks.
You can actually
see how it breaks.
It's breaking along
the weakest plane.
So if you want to think,
then, about well, OK,
how do I know how to make
this stronger, for example?
So it stops breaking--
you know, the weakest link
is the weakest link.
That was deep.
So then that's the
plane of the crystal
that I need to think about.
How are bonding together or
packing in in that plane?
This is real stuff.
This comes about in many
of the properties, not just
the fracture, but in many of the
properties of these materials.
The property, as I said before,
depends heavily on which plane
you're in.
And we'll see that
more and more.
As one last example of this,
you could go a little--
So again, you go back
to your periodic table.
And you take-- there was copper.
Let's do nickel.
All right, you take nickel.
And let's see, I know that
the atomic radius of nickel
is 1.52 angstroms.
I've looked that up.
But I also know that it's BCC.
And this gives it away.
This gives me what I need.
The crystal symmetry, the
lattice, gives me what I need.
Because once I
know that it's BCC,
then I also know
that the lattice edge
goes as 4r over root 3.
Remember, for an
element like nickel,
the packing direction is
along the body diagonal.
That's what gave me this
relationship, back and forth.
Unit cell edge,
radius of the atom.
So that means that in
nickel, it's 3.5 angstroms.
And once I know what a is, well
then I can know what like the--
you know, in one of the planes
I say, which plane is that?
I don't know, let's look at
the densities in the plane.
So for the 100 plane, it's--
I'm just going to
give you the answer--
0.59 is the packing fraction.
Packing density.
This is the-- sorry,
that's the fraction.
All I did is I used
the periodic table
to do what I just did
for the simple cubic case
but now for BCC.
And it's because
of all the things
that we've learned in the
last two days, in the last two
lectures that we're able to
do this kind of calculation.
And I can compare this
plane with another plane
with another plane.
And think about how the
atoms are packed differently
within the anisotropy
of the crystal.
OK, Friday, bring parents.
Bring parents.